السيد الرئيس
أولاً ، أود أن أشكرك جزيل الشكر
لاستقبالي على
مقابلة. انطباعنا
أن الغرب بشكل أساسي الولايات المتحدة
يسلم القفازات مع الإرهابيين
الذين اختلقوا القصة بأكملها من
أجل الحصول على ذريعة للهجوم
الذي لم يتم مهاجمته.  بسبب ما
حدث في هانشير ،
إنها حدث واحد ، إنها مرحلة أولى المسرحية
التي رأيناها على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وعلى شاشات
التلفزيون
والدعاية والمرحلة الثانية
بالهجوم العسكري
نعطي أمرًا بضرب هانشر
هون بالسلاح الكيميائي يوم الثلاثاء الماضي.
لا أعرف ما إذا كان هؤلاء القتلى
والأطفال الذين
تم اختطافهم هم القتلى
على الإطلاق ممن
ارتكبوا الهجوم إذا كان هناك هجوم ما هي
المواد
التي ليس لديك أي معلومات
على الإطلاق لم يتم التحقيق فيها على الإطلاق ،
لذا فأنت تعتقد أنها اختلاق
بالتأكيد
مائة بالمائة لهذا.  كان التلفيق
ممتعًا
جدًا شكرًا جزيلاً
لك